okay so the reason to give this talk is
number one I don't know anything about
deep learning so I do know a little bit
about SQL and I do know that SQL if you
really think about it it's probably like
the original Big Data technology SQL is
a very old technology it came out in
1974 so we're talking about something
that came out in 1974 with historical
standardization in 1986 ANSI
standardization and then standardization
further standardizations in 92 99 2003
2006 2008 2011 and 2016 so it's a very
old technology that is absolutely
ubiquitous that people are still adding
onto unfortunately I think this is one
of those like you learn in school type
technologies you know if you talk to
anybody who learnt computer programming
in grad school there's this list of
technologies that they learn once 10
years ago and they never really bothered
to refresh on like make or shell or SQL
or even things like matplotlib some of
you here are still writing matplotlib
like it's 2003 but it's a tool that's
under active development and there are
new and proper ways to do things that
might have been difficult a long time
ago I think this is actually why it's
relevant to talk about SQL even in 2018
because even for such an old technology
it still is a very actively developed
technology and are very powerful and
robust and mature technology so I'll
give you the broad agenda of where we're
going now the goal of this talk is to
talk about data modeling and relational
data modeling I think that data modeling
is one of the most interesting things
that we can do as computer programmers
it is the hardest part of our work to
actually automate because it requires
really fundamentally understanding a
business domain and reducing the the
complexity the infinite profundity of
the real world to something that a
machine can automate it requires a lot
of insight and a lot of thought and a
lot of vision in terms of what the tool
that you're building actually does
I want to talk about the data modeling
or maybe the SQL approach and some
interesting features you might not know
that are actually in SQL a couple of
things which you might have thought are
very difficult turned out to be fairly
easy so things like managing tree
structures simple features like common
table expressions the idea of temporal
modeling and how powerful an idea this
is and some additional mechanics like
window functions and some SQL DDL
mechanics so when I started writing the
notes for this talk at 4 a.m. last night
this seems like a really funny joke so
the agenda is this the V gender get it
like this an agenda and as the agenda
yeah really seemed really funny at 4:00
a.m. what we're gonna do is we're going
to create some rules for a simple game
we're gonna define some queries for that
game and we're gonna try and model
certain aspects of the game well use a
game rather than the typical example of
payroll or some business problem it's a
little bit more interesting and it
allows us to do things that are a little
bit more complicated
without seeming to synthetic now I want
to tell you what the no Genda is that's
what we won't talk about here this
really seemed like a funny joke last
night the no gender is to talk about
things which I don't think are actually
that interesting such as the boring
details of the SQL standards they are
excruciatingly boring documents and
there are many many of them things like
performance one of the reasons why I
think people still like SQL is not that
it's necessarily a more performant
technology so much that the performance
of SQL is well understood if you have an
SQL database or some queries and they're
slow the mechanics of how to make that
fast are well understood it really is
from the perspective of a business let's
just throw money at it because there are
plenty of people who have expertise and
tuning Oracle or Postgres or one of
these other tools and the actual details
of how to do that has been covered to
death so we won't talk too much about
performance what we'll do is we'll talk
more about modeling and what what you're
capable of doing so that's the general
idea of where we're going to go in this
talk
I will live code this entire talk so
what I will do is just to set the
baseline and the Z gender will focus on
Postgres because it's probably one of
the best open-source SQL databases that
we have access to it has a lot of really
interesting features it's open source
it's free to use it is a fantastic
mature sophisticated tool we will use
certain features that are specific to
Postgres so we'll ignore things that are
maybe in the standard but not
generalized throughout all the different
products and it allow us to be a little
bit more specific in this talk so as I
said the example that I want to do and I
want to motivate some of these things
with a very concrete example example I
want to give you as of a game because
this is you know one of the most
interesting data modeling exercises I've
had to do recently I was thinking of
creating a collaborative coding game a
game for teaching coding I think I
briefly talked about this last year and
a lightning talk at PI day to Berlin I
haven't been working that actively on it
it's taken me a year to do very little
work but as you can see even a fairly
simple set of rules leads to an
interesting opportunity to look into how
the database allows us to model
information to enforce constraints and
how it drives us to really firmly
understand the technology so here's my
set of rules I like space games and I
like I like space TV shows and space
books so we'll think about a turn-based
game with multiple players and because
we're talking about a big data
technology one thing that we'll keep in
mind is let's assume that this game can
have hundreds or thousands of players
and so the amount of actual data that
we're storing can be immense for the
purposes of our examples we'll do only
things that we can type but we can
imagine that anything that we see here
should be trivially extendable to a case
of actual big data where you have lots
of real-time data coming in from
simultaneous clients and all of the
considerations thereof we'll do a space
game so it'll be like a space combat
game you'll have some civilizations
those are the players each civilization
will have some units those are some
spaceships
what can spaceships do they compute you
on each other so they can fight each
other they have some score for how much
they attack each other how much they can
defend themselves now I don't believe in
fast in the light
so instead we have like systems like
solar systems and the spaceships can
move between them so think about just
squares on a board they can move between
them and so the position of any unit is
discreet you're either orbiting one
planet or orbiting another but we don't
care about what happens in transit and
just like a game like Starcraft there's
some capacity mechanic so there's some
question of do you win you win by
controlling the most territory
what considered to control the territory
is that you have the most units in some
particular space on the board so you can
think this is a fairly simple game it's
actually fairly simple to even games
like Stratego and the rule set even
though it's it's very small actually
ends up being fairly rich in terms of
modeling we'll also assume that the way
that the players interact with the game
is that they'll issue orders our system
will take in those orders there'll be
some game engine that just goes through
those orders and pops them off and
processes them we won't write the game
engine and I'll tell you why in a moment
but we'll assume that they can just tell
a ship individually fire on this ship or
maneuver those are the two typical
things you can do move and fire and
that's it so it's a fairly simple it's a
fairly simple set of mechanics and we'll
see how this leads to some data modeling
now the next thing that we want to think
about are what are the queries that we
would encounter here we're looking when
we talk about SQL oftentimes we ignore
that it's really three separate
languages that share a very clumsy
common syntax when people talk about SQL
they're talking about a query language
SQL they talk about DML a data modeling
language and they talk about DDL a sorry
data modification language and they talk
about DDL a data definition language and
even though they share the same syntax
or they share a similar type of syntax
and they have some similarities within
them they are in fact three fairly
distinct things we won't see very
clearly how they're distinct but one
thing that you can imagine is as Python
programmers one of the things that we're
very used to and one of the conveniences
that we rely upon is the availability of
an incredibly dynamic system in which to
write code so if you think about it one
of the things that one of the work
mechanics that defined your use of a
language like C or C++
you write some code you compile it you
go to lunch you come back and you run
your tests and in Python you don't seem
to have that very strict barrier between
write some code something happens as a
compilation step and then you run your
tests it seems to be a little bit
smoother
similarly in C and C++ it seems like
everything's a little bit more static
you can't monkey patch things at runtime
you can't change the way the language
works everything seems that needs to
have a very fixed layout in memory and
that layout exists every time or is
determined by the compiler and only just
at compile time and there's no runtime
representation of that bear in mind as
we look at SQL and as you look at SQL
more deeply in your careers this is a
very old technology
from 1974 so that makes it 44 years old
that's ancient is there anyone here
who's 44 and if you're 44 years old
you're as old as SQL it's that's you're
over your that's that's really old one
of the things is when you look when you
look at the history of programming
languages you'll see that certain things
that we take for granted like a very
clear understanding of what static and
what's dynamic or even things like
modularity and functions and methods and
objects actually post-date things like
SQL so the modern programming
environment the things we say a
programming language has to have to be a
programming language post-date SQL is a
technology this is a very old technology
this is why in many cases it seems
incredibly clumsy to do things that are
absolutely trivial okay so let's
actually get into the weeds of what
we're gonna do so here's my little
directory I'll probably put this on
github at some point actually no I won't
tweet at me if you want me to put this
on github if you don't tweet at me I
won't so you really want to see the
materials for this you got a tweet at me
that's how you increase engagement
there's a couple of SQL files and I'm
gonna do everything in SQL files so I
have four files here there's helpers dot
SQL modeled at SQL data SQL and queries
rescue and I've got a make file that you
know helps things make things a little
bit easy and there's one little trick
I'll do every time I save one of these
files you see it it really quickly
blinked a bunch of stuff on the bottom
every time I save this thing let me
actually
zoom down there I'm I save this it'll
just rerun my tests in the background so
you'll see a couple of tests and what
I'll do is go this one has a little bit
of extra code in here I'll just delete
that delete that like that and so I'll
just remove the code that's here because
we'll write it ourselves this is the
first piece of code we'll write just
remove that you can see there's an error
because my files are incomplete now of
these files the first one has helpers
that SQL is just some helper functions
it really isn't that interesting what's
in here you know every project you start
with has a bunch of stuff that you that
you carry from project to project
there's just a couple of helper
functions nothing too interesting we
will split this project into three parts
we'll do some data modeling will
actually insert some test data and then
we'll run some queries on this so we'll
actually see the wide gamut of
everything that can be done in SQL now
let's actually get into this so I told
you at the very beginning that we have
some players in our games right and we
represent these as civilizations so the
two classical civilizations that we have
in our game are the earthers and the
spacers anyone tell me something about
earthers they're lazy they're
overpopulated they live in caves of
steel underground they're an absolute
mess and we have the spacers there
arrowed I dress very nicely they're very
tall but they're an existential crisis
because they over rely on robots and
we'll never have a demographic crisis
and they'll never be able to to survive
a war with the earthers the earthers
tend to be more populated in the spacers
tend to be more technologically adept
that has no bearing on the rest of this
talk I thought I would just share that
with you but we have some beginning part
so let's think about how we model this
well this is a really easy thing to
model but one thing I want you to keep
in mind and I'll just show you before I
get to deeper um each one of these files
is in like one of the things that's
actually worth really understanding if
you're doing SQL is the idea of data
first modeling the idea that for many of
you when you have relational data and
you will always run into relational data
usually we'll reach for an ORM if you
think about the actual work that you do
and the actual data sources that you
deal with it's all
in the case that the core of the problem
that you're trying to solve fits into a
numpy and DRA or fits into a panda's
data frame it's strictly columnar data
or it's strictly matrix data and the
core the meat of the problem the thing
that the deep learning person comes on
stage to talk about is just a bunch of
multiplications of those tensors or
multiplications of those numpy and the
arrays or just some indexing and
interpolation on that pandas not afraid
but when you actually have to fit it
into a real business problem you start
getting a relational data you start
getting business entities that don't
really have operational meaning within
the system that they're not part of some
ndra they have some complex set of rules
governing what they can look like and
those rules are defined by the dynamics
of the business environment on which
they sit when you start so this is
actually a fairly good fit for SQL SQL
succeeds at modeling business problems
where you have relational data when you
start getting deeper into SQL it's
worthwhile to actually read through the
documentation so that when you're
writing SQL files you can actually write
kind of nice ones like this like you can
see there's a little bit of echoing when
these run you know as I'm running my
tests it has my follow me this is called
engagement always print on every slide
follow me at what I've learned that from
somebody at PI data you know you have
nice logging here I put everything
inside transactions and so there's a
little bit of I'll start with a little
bit of framework here just to make my
life easier and a common set of
frameworks that one should start with
and writing SQL so as I said we have
some civilizations so very simple to
model it we just create a table now
before we create a table one thing that
we need to know and Postgres is there's
this idea of schemas these are table
spaces they go by a lot of different
names of different standards when we are
modeling this problem we have to think
fundamentally about what kind of queries
were going to apply to this data so if
we think about the the business entities
that exist in this system there are
entities that represent the game as
defined and there's business entities
that represent the game as its played
the business entities that represent the
game as defined will fit into a schema
called game they're like who are the
players once the game starts the players
don't change they will be what they look
what the board looks like once the game
starts you can't add or remove units
from the board but between games you
might change what the board looks like
because you might want to play bigger
games or smaller games
what the units in that game are the
units definition of the types of units
won't change between game won't change
within a game but they may change
between games so there's some
information that's not fully static but
only really changes between instances of
a play of the game and that's what's
going to fit into the schema and the
first one is an idea of who the players
are so this is a very simple table to
create and we'll do a couple of things
that we typically do on these we'll give
it a phony primary key so that a couple
of queries will be easier later which is
an ID key and just some name like that
and then when we run everything we can
see everything runs and our little query
down here for selecting the two the two
players works this is pretty easy now
the next thing we might want to do with
me why I want to define what the units
in the game look like and I told you
that the units have some attack they
have some defense they have some
entities like that so we could do the
same thing so again it has some primary
key and now we get to see some things
that are a little bit more interesting
it has maybe a name for the unit so what
kind of ship it is it has some attack
value maybe that's how much damage it
does if attacks we can set defaults when
you think about your ORM style all of
this you could do with an ORM but what
gets really hard is to start adding
simple constraints and if you think
about this we have already in our data
first approach done something that is
essentially very difficult to do in a
guaranteed fashion with an ORM approach
which is to add constraints that ensure
that the database is always in a
consistent state now one of the reasons
that we will practice this data force
modeling is that the actual clients that
interact with this game may change over
time that the logic that we have in
those clients might might require a lot
of rep
petition to enforce constraints like we
don't have ships that have a negative
attack rating or a negative defense
rating or cost a negative amount of
money and you can think within the logic
of the client within the logic of the
game engine there's a lot of places
where you have to check these things you
might as well centralize those checks in
the database if you think about the
database itself it is a very complicated
piece of software and to use it as just
a dumb store is an absolute waste so
that's kind of what it looks like for
our units now we can do things on this
like create indices we won't really do
that for this talk it'll take up too
much of the very little time that we
have left but you can think we can
create indices now the other thing that
we might want to do is we want to create
the units on the board and we'll call
them solar systems so create table and
again it looks very similar to before in
fact they all have this about the same
fields now one thing that I'm trying to
do here is also encourage you when
you're writing your SQL please don't
write it like it's like it's a you know
1982 like that you know you don't have
to anymore SQL is not really the key
words are not case-sensitive you know
don't give names to the fields like you
know system name this proper name
spacing and you'll see me use this later
on there's proper name spacing and
disambiguation of where things come from
just as in Python try and give things
reasonable human readable human
understandable names now with that the
only last piece that I really need in
order to complete my definition of what
the game looks like is the wormholes
that connect connect each system and I
don't need I don't and I can say this
just goes from some system and it goes
to some system so here I can define you
can think I I'm creating a more
generalized board than like a square
board and one thing I can do is I can
enforce that these are unique
so there's only one way to get from one
place to another okay so here I have a
fairly simple exercise where I've
modeled the state of the game entirely
and you can see if not for two typos one
here and one here everything just works
now with that I can start nted I can
start actually creating elements in my
data set to represent the state of the
game now just to save a little bit of
time I'll do a little bit of cut and
paste from my notes so because you don't
really want to see see me type that much
oops look at that that works oh I want
to do this I'll just do it by hand unit
name attack/defense cost values we'll do
create three types of Units like little
fighters frigates and maybe capital
ships and then we'll create three
systems and I'll tried really hard to do
ones that I can type correctly now one
thing that you can think that's
interesting here is I've actually
defined that these are static pieces
information but they're not really
you could change these over the lifetime
of the game you could add units as the
game evolves but for the simplicity of
this example we want now if I wanted to
in my queries I could do something like
select star from civilizations select
star from systems and you can see
everything just works now as I get into
the dynamic data that the data that
actually represents the game state I
start to see some things that are a
little bit more complicated where I need
to do some more complicated constraints
and modeling I need to do more
complicated queries let me show you two
of those the first of them is every
player has some ships that they have
right and as we go into this we'll see
there some things that are very
difficult to do automatically with an
ORM but turn out to be very easy and
very clean to just define if we take
this approach of writing SQL real SQL
properly so we create a table like that
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say a ship belongs to some civilization
a ship has some unit type units I ship
sits in some system and a ship has some
damage that it has a crude okay and
everything still works now there's one
thing that I want you to think about
right here something very interesting
all of you probably have some baseline
familiarity with SQL you know select you
know insert you know update if you think
about those three verbs from the most
naive perspective what thing that you
might think is okay an entity on a table
represents an active entity I insert it
to create an active entity I select to
view select is a very interesting but
pretty distinct verb but when that
entity no longer exists like when the
ship is destroyed maybe I delete it from
the table when the ship moves I probably
update I probably update what system
it's in when the ship takes damage I
update this and if you try and take that
same thought process and you apply to
some real-world business problems you'll
see that sometimes it breaks down for
example going back to the typical
example that people use when talking
about SQL the salary table you have
employees on a table if an employee's in
the table it's an active employee when
you update the salary the employees
salary column that means they got a
raise when you delete an employee from
that table no means the employee has
been fired well here's a problem you
fire an employee three months later you
need to do some tax accounting you go
back to your database and you say uh-oh
I removed that row I can't do anything
or you accidentally give an employee a
raise and you realize I won't need to
rewind you to the previous salary
what was that value and one of the
typical responses is something like this
is people will do something like a des
if valid or they'll make these databases
insert only they'll say really if I
wanted to make this a complete
completely consistent model I really
shouldn't have the damage here I should
have another table that represents all
the attacks that are done and then I'll
do some aggregate function on that I'll
do a row I'll do a MapReduce on that and
I'll give me the damage and then I'll
fold that together the problem is you'll
end up taking this very rich vocabulary
that SQL has of these core three
modification verbs update insert and
delete and you'll reduce it to just
insert only you'll have some insert only
append only store and it will be
consistent but it'll be much much less
rich let me show you one of the key
solutions and one of the key things
missing to almost every initial data
model whenever people are modeling
relational data and it's a concept
called by tempor ality here's the core
idea i want to know the history of my
database every time there's a change
every time our row changes I want to
store some information representing what
that world looked like originally I want
to be able to use the core verbs of
insert delete and update to represent
exactly what they say they mean delete
means this is no longer active update
means this changed insert means is a new
entity when I update and delete I want
to retain the history of what that table
looks like before so I can rewind to any
point in time and say what did this
table look like as of this point in the
game because as we start to model this
deeper one thing that you could think
that's actually fairly interesting is if
people are actually playing this game
and after they're done playing this game
will have captured a lot of information
about how the players played how they
move their units around which somebody
could then take and read in in order to
figure out strategies this is useful
data for analyzing strategies you could
pull this into a panda's data frame and
try to do some kind of guessing around
what strategies were employed by
different players but only if you had
the historical view of all the table the
SQL 2003 standard it's 2003 or 2006 and
at a concept of full temporality here's
what it means for records in a database
oftentimes they'll have some number of
time stamps associated with them if they
are time series data like for example
when you issue an order the time when
you issue that order is meaningful if
it's something like a ship then there's
no natural time stamp on it for every
one of those columns we add one more
time stamp which is often called a
system time or knowledge time the idea
is we want to record in this table what
is the road look like what is the time
that represents that row like what was
the time of the measurement we talked
and what was the time which the system
knew on that measurement
this tends to be a very complicated
thing to do manually and originally in
databases people will do this manually
that's something like an AZ of column
and they do a bunch of junk here and
they'd have if you think about it for
the employee example what they do is
that add a column called is current
employee and they toggle it from true to
false when somebody leaves so the
database would just be insert only and
you just be adding rows very very
wasteful because you end up having a
really big dot a really big table with
mostly dead employees if you have high
turnover I want to show you something
that actually is really nice about SQL
really nice about Postgres there's a
folder here in my repo called bitemporal
and in this folder I have two files that
I won't actually edit one of them is a
simple shell script that just goes
through every single one of the tables
that I have and it will identify tables
that aren't history tables or aren't
internal use tables and it'll just run a
simple Jinja template on some templated
SQL and the template at SQL just looks
like this a couple of alter tables and a
little trigger in in Postgres there is a
user provided plugin that you can find
on github that's on the wikipedia page
talking about full temper ality that
adds full temper ality to a Postgres
database it's just a plugin and it's
just a snippet of SQL that you run
against every table it's the exact same
snippet of SQL that you run against
every single table so this snippet here
I use for every single project
I don't even change it in fact I should
probably add a pull request to the
original project to just give it to them
so that you could just run that plug-in
against every table let me show you what
it does I'll go into my make file and
I'll just turn on my my little thing
that runs my by temple I'll show you
what happens okay
I'll run this and I'll look at my tables
now just make sure I did that right
just by temporal oh I need to do it here
as well okay and if I go into my shell
here here are my solar systems you can
see it automatically inserted this as of
table what this as of table represents
the system time it represents the time
which this row is active in my active
table every system or actually do it on
ships which will change right actually
let me insert some ships first and I'll
show you this example so I'll do insert
into ships station unit system and as I
said the spacers have very high
technology so they have a capital ship
spacers
and we'll just stick it there okay then
we'll run our test and then we'll look
at the results in our shell so you can
see there's one row here now let's say
the ship is destroyed what I might do is
I might do a delete from ships where ID
equals one this is our naive approach
and when I look at the ship's it's gone
but when I want the history this plug-in
whoops
actually stored warehouse all the
information if I can type this right
warehouse all the information
representing that so every time a record
has changed I get I get a I get that
record stored automatically for me I'll
show you that again here's my ship let's
update the system let's say it moved
right if I look at my history table what
I can see is I stored all the
information about the history of this
and this is a feature in SQL called
table inheritance what happens when I
query from this table is I actually see
the entire historical view of everything
that happened and that adds of column is
a date range for when that row was
active so here I have all the benefits
of full temporary I can always ask my
database
give me the state of the game as of this
point in time and it can tell me exactly
what the state of the game looked at as
any point in time but that the the
schema is that the the table definition
I have can actually use these night this
naive approach for the verbs so there we
go with that now let me do the following
let me let me go into my notes and I'll
add a couple more ships
and really rather cut and paste this so
we'll add a bunch more ships and a bunch
more places and we'll look at the next
part of this boy those those dirty
spacers blowing up my cut and paste see
if my cut and paste works ah there we go
so we added a bunch more ships
thank goodness for cut and paste and let
me just make sure I pasted that right
oh this is a fighter
was it gold and this is it
forget up we gotta do one more thing
capital we'll try this one more time and
then figure out which of these is wrong
okay yeah no no I'll wrap up so so the
next part that I'm going to do we'll get
that to work in just one second but the
next part that I want to do is I want to
show you how we can do the control and
the control is a fairly difficult thing
to get right and I just want to get this
working serious oh there's one more
problem in here or let's just remove
these two and we'll get this working I
want to show you the last part of this
which is how we actually figure out how
to do a complex query here so let's say
that we want to figure out who controls
what unit of space that's a fairly
complex query what we might do is we
might select star from the ships and we
might select it from the ships in the
systems so we can see every ship in
every system and we might do a join here
so I might select star from the ships or
them systems join the ships on the on
the IDs being the same so that's every
ship in every system let me make this a
little bit easier to read so that's
every system and we'll see every ship in
every system oops so that's every ship
in every system now one of the things
that we end up doing we don't take a
data first or query first approach is we
end up implementing a lot of very simple
SQL query logic in our application layer
and so we end up doing lots of
round-trip queries where a single
concrete SQL statement can do it much
more effectively I want to show you an
example of that and then once I show you
an example that I'm gonna switch over to
my pre-prepared version of this and I'll
show you one or two things that were a
little bit harder no I'll skip the
questions so let me show you this one of
the things I want to do is I want to
figure out who has the most ships in
which
in which area of space and so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna do a window
function I'm going to take this
information and I'm going to compute the
rank over our petition of this
information partitioned by sis by the
system name and what I get when I do
that and that's order by and I have to
do a group by at the end there we go so
this is this is the the ranking of how
many this is the ranking of how many
civilizations have what ships in what
places in this case you can see actually
let me switch over to the pre-prepared
version it's a little bit easier to see
in that one
there we go and so you can see in this
pre-prepared version I have a bunch of
ships in a bunch of places and you can
see in one case in this one system
there's two civilizations that have the
same rank now I can make this a little
bit easier to read by doing one more
join there I can make this a little bit
easier to read and I'll do this as you
don't name and you'll see that a query
like this is actually much easier to do
in a single form than you think so there
you can see we have some contention here
where in this particular system two
people have the same same civilization
or the same thing and this is what's
called a window function essentially
when I'm doing this processing
oftentimes what we'll do is we'll put a
bunch of data we'll stick it into a
panda's data frame and we'll do window
functions on that will look at
partitions of it but it turns out the
SQL standard is much richer than that
can do some of these window functions
itself much more efficiently than you
think the way to actually resolve this
to figure out what I want to do then I
have two minutes okay so let me let me
let me finish this example and then I'll
show you so the end of this example
looks like this
which is that I end up creating a
materialized view over this information
with a window function that then allows
me to identify these unfortunately I ran
out of time to show you the entire
example but you can see the general idea
here is that it's a very rich language
with a lot of very sophisticated ways to
do two things even for an example here
with a very simple set of rules you can
start adding extra constraints there are
a couple of things I didn't have time to
show you in the model itself which was
the idea that we can also do tree data
we cannot reduce trees structure data
where you tell one ship to do one thing
and it cascades to everything else
within the database itself you can do
sophisticated things like this
materialized views wherein you kind of
partition the information you look for
systems where everybody has the same
number of units and you eliminate them
very sophisticated queries they're
otherwise impossible to do with an ORM
and from this approach we end up having
a data store that's itself consistent
and force a lot of the business logic
can have raw queries against it and
leads to a very thin very simple and
very easy to write application layer
thank you
[Applause]